هناك أكثر من 85 مليون أمريكي
يواجهون خطر العواصف الشديدة من
ديترويت على طول الطريق إلى ديريك
فان دام من تكساس سي إن إن ، ويبدو أن كل هذا يبدو
وكأنه تهديد للطقس لمدة أسبوع ،
وأدرك ديريك أن هناك تهديدًا نشطًا
في هذه اللحظة بالذات
حسنًا يا جون ، هذا
إعداد ديناميكي شديد للطقس ليس فقط لدينا
ساعة إعصار حيث أقف في
ليتل روك ولكن في الشمال توجد
عواصف شديدة عبر منطقة شيكاغو الكبرى
ولكني أريد أن أبدأ بلقطة أفق
وسط مدينة شيكاغو
بإطلالة على بحيرة ميشيغان ، هذه
صورة رائعة منذ لحظات فقط لتظهر
لك القوة الحقيقية لهذه العواصف التي
تتحرك من خلالها ونحن نتحدث هذه هي
سحابة الرف التي تنظر إليها في
الجانب الخلفي من هذا الخط من
العواصف القوية التي جلبت  من 50 إلى 60 ميلًا في
الساعة رياحًا ويصل قطرها إلى بوصة واحدة ،
ولكن إذا نظرت عن كثب إلى
الماء هناك ، يمكنك رؤية التموجات
هناك ولكن يمكنك فقط رؤية مدى
قوة الرياح التي
تحركت مؤخرًا عبر وسط مدينة شيكاغو
تسبب في توقفات أرضية في أوهير مما تسبب في
توقفات أرضية وتأخيرات في ميدواي أيضًا